fait aux cheveux de fabien roussel vous
allez à peut compresser les photos noms
de personnes qui deviendront aussi
approximatif mais jean lassalle a
toujours de la chose les grilles jean
luc mélenchon et ça c'est la photo qui
le détestent faites attention si vous la
repasse il n'arrivera plus jamais
je suis stressé qui me voient sans fil
que thuan est très exigeant sur le
physique
j'aime bien les beaux corps même les
corps tu nous tiens j'ai encore un petit
peu en forme de guitare
je crois pas qu'ils aient des vues ou
encore en photo en entier c'est pas que
j'ai des hanches
comme ça il ya une quasi qui a fait
énormément parler c'est la photo de marc
lynch à part au meeting elle était
présente sur les réseaux sociaux elle a
été très violemment critiqué marlène
schiappa voilà ça a été très violent je
vous dis regardez on va voir les
quelques tweets 1 voilà qui ont qui ont
été postés on mange bien la cantine de
lille
après je la trouve pas du tout comme sur
les photos
lm10 du compliment mais moi j'arrive
paraît prendre des compléments parce que
je suis un homme vrai moi je pensais pas
qu'elle monte à ce point là au début
quand même me dis ouais tu vas ne
s'appelle pas en visio parce que ça sert
à rien on garde le suspense j'en ai j'en
ai pris pour la rigolade mais quand jeu
suivant elle lassée de strabag en jeu je
m'attendais à voir une voiture de luxe
et a su pousser un chèque au convoi
qu'est ce que vous nous cachez la
toussaint petter alors ça c'est pour la
personne qui sera la moins sympathiques
à table après l'apéro bah je vais
réserver une petite surprise de taille
vous on vous en prie faites mais une
démonstration
mais déjà quand il a dit j'ai révisé 4-1
et puis il a l'air tellement font faire
on le voit quoi il est il porte sur lui
il prend vos produits bien-être il a
quand même 72 ans on est con sa façon
c'est comme vous nagra the
nile voulez rire vous et
je suis toujours que vaut votre âge
[Musique]
c'est vraiment pas te faire ta pathos
pas et puisque depuis deux ans quoi
attaquer quoi tu me trouves quoi c'est
pas ce soit anvers
je m'attendais pas à ça je suis déçu
franchement pour un premier dessin s'est
pas éteinte one différente de ce que
j'ai connu
en virtuel je suis jeune
c'est pas d'accord ok je respecte si moi
je suis pas
vraiment attention car je respecte tu
sois pas encore après tu vois vraiment
du produit laitier mais si tu lui voler
ça veut dire qu'on a tué le vote utile
et il y aura aussi un petit avis euros
interoute & tina hydro
utilisé
j'en ai conclu que tu est l'amour de ma
vie
le bundle
couple franco belge tout ça tout ça
voilà je pense qu'on a des choses à te
voilà moi j'attends
un non pas des marques comme ça
j'essaie de change pas mais tu peux pas
faire ça c'est des pollueurs de la
planète c'est méchant moi je dis mais
c'est pas possible pour moi c'est pas
possible je veux pas me réveiller
quelqu'un qui ment chaconne moi ça
n'existe pas tout à refaire mais toi
j'ai tout de l'éducation parents
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
grammy de la chanson l'année a été
remporté par anderson pâques et bruno
mars qui s'en est grillé une pour fêter
ça celui du meilleur duo pop est revenu
à s z à et de jack hat qui a déboulé des
wc en catastrophe
[Applaudissements]
ça passe